president Trump's top diplomat says the
US will not ease sanctions against North
Korea until it D nuclear Laura let's
just say it gets rid of its news
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo was in
Beijing to discuss the North Korea
summit with Chinese leaders
correspondent Richardson is in Beijing
right now Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
s week long Asia trip focused on
disarming North Korea's nuclear arsenal
concludes here with a commitment from
China to maintain pressure on North
Korea China has reaffirmed its
commitment to honoring the UN Security
Council resolutions the sanctions and
the economic relief that North Korea
will receive will only happen after the
full denuclearization the complete
denuclearization of North Korea the
Secretary of State also met with China's
foreign minister and other senior
officials at the Ministry of Foreign
Affairs China wants a reduced US
military presence in the region and
approves of the president Trump's
decision to suspend military exercises
with South Korea earlier in the day
Pompeo was in Seoul meeting with South
Korean president moon jae-in and the
foreign ministers from South Korea and
Japan he defended the president's
decision to suspend the exercises saying
if North Korea fails to negotiate in
good faith the US will simply restore
those drills Pompeo says those
discussions will also involve an intense
accounting of the size and scope of Kim
Jong Un's nuclear program we have a
reasonable understanding we will work
with the North Koreans to come to have a
full understanding of that so that we
can begin to execute together the
commitments the president Trump and
Chairman Kim made
in Pyongyang North Korean leaders are
also commemorating the Singapore summit
releasing a video showing chairman Kim's
experience and in one scene the
President of the United States saluting
a general from North Korea this trip for
secretary Pompeo also featured
persistent questions as to what exactly
North decreed - in Singapore one
journalist asked why phrasing the
administration has been using for weeks
like verifiable and irreversible was
omitted from the final document
president trumping kim jong un's side
secretary Pompeo says it did include
complete denuclearization which covers
those terms and said that question was
insulting ridiculous and frankly
ludicrous brett richardson live in
beijing traveling with the secretary
rich thanks